What does everybody have but most people
dread?
Small talk. You're probably here because
you want to get better at small talk and
you're in the right place because my
name's Chad and my partner in crime and
I wrote a book called Ask Powerful
Questions, Create Conversations That
Matter and it's been at the time of
recording it's been sitting as a number
one best seller on Amazon for several
years and I love hearing from people who
it's helped make conversations go beyond
small talk to conversations that really
matter. And so in this video I'm going
to share if you were to pick out only
one really key strategy to have better
small talk I'm going to share that with
you in this video. Let's not waste any
time. Let's get into it.
So the tool that I'm going to share with
you
I like to call the awkward elevator tool
and the reason I call it that is that's
the you know the the situation that is
typically associated with the most
extreme painful small talk. You're in an
elevator you've got nothing else to talk
about except what's in that elevator and
even imagine that there are strangers in
there. Now granted most of the time you
don't actually spark conversation with
those people but if you had to this tool
would get you out of that rut. But it
also is remarkably useful if you're at a
networking meeting or you're at a work
Christmas party or
boss said you need to go team build and
you're stuck
in some capacity with your colleagues.
This tool will help you have more
meaningful conversations in all of those
contexts. And before I just drop the
tool on you we have to unpack why have
more conversations. So let me just get
super nerdy for a minute and read you
two sentences from the book that really
stuck out to me when I was actually
writing in this section of the book and
doing the research on the science of
asking really great questions and
creating conversations that matter. So
the American Psychological Association
did a study on over 20,000 audio
recordings of people's conversation in
everyday life. And what they found was
that people who had more authentic
substantive conversations also tended to
be happier which I love because I think
that sometimes we think about creating
conversations that matter as you know
important to not have awkward
conversation and that's great and I
think that creating conversations that
matter isn't just fun it's actually
essential to our health and well-being.
So this awkward elevator tool very
simply is comes in chapter two of the
book. In the book we unpack this layer
and five different mindsets and tools to
be able to ask better questions and
create conversations that matter. I'm
going to share number two with you. And
it's this idea of rapport which we
define as a relationship of trust. So
ideally small talk is intended to
establish a relationship of trust. And
so the tool that we share is to follow
your own natural genuine curiosity based
on what someone is wearing, carrying,
sharing or presenting.
How did we come up with those? So quick
rewind Will and I
created and and taught this tool to
people working for an organization
where we were training facilitators to
walk into a room full of strangers and
have meaningful conversations about
difficult topics. So they had no other
context there was nothing else to ask
about other than what they walked in the
room with. And what we found is that
even though you think the conversation
starts with words the conversation
started long before that with what
people brought into the room with them.
The conversation was started based on
what they're sharing, based on what
they're wearing, based on the jewelry
that they have on, right? This means
something has a story behind it, based
on people's emotion, based on what
they're actually carrying with them into
the room, based on how clean or dirty
their shoes are might mean they've been
adventuring or they have been cleaning
their shoe right there's all of this
data that's actually shared with us
before the conversation's even begun. So
even though you think you have to start
a conversation from scratch there's
actually a whole bunch of stuff already
on the table. And so the tool is look,
right? Notice
be curious and inquire ask a question
rooted in your natural genuine curiosity
based on what someone is wearing,
carrying, sharing or presenting. And the
reason this tool is so incredibly
impactful is that when you talk to
people typically they know that they
were going to be out in public today and
so they we choose as human beings we
choose what we put on our bodies and
bring with us to represent a little part
of who we are. And so it's a very safe
way to skip past some of the like
questions that people get very tired of
which is where you from which usually
ends with like you doing some weird
geography game and then conversation
done or what do you do and they answer
that question and you're like
not what I do
right? Conversation over. Those are
often times conversation killers because
people have already had those dialogues
so many times. And so even applying this
tool though to what someone is sharing
is really useful. So
where are you from? Boston. Typically
we'd say oh I have a cousin that lives
in Boston. Not useful for small talk,
right? You think it might be useful for
small talk to jump in and share a
commonality. What is more useful is if
you follow your natural curiosity based
on what they've said and ask them a
question. So oh cool Boston. What was it
like growing up in Boston? I grew up in
the Midwest. Do you see how that had a
little bit of self-disclosure but also
followed your curiosity? Just in case
this idea is not really sinking in take
this question with you. What are you
curious about right now?
As kids we ask so many questions every
single day and as adults we've been
trained to speak in sentences that end
in periods rather than sentences that
end in question marks. And the best way
to get better at small talk is to tap
into your curiosity and curiosity is a
choice by the way. We can choose to turn
up the dial and pay attention to the
things that are around us that a
person's wearing and follow that
curiosity. This tool can be misused so
it's really important to go back to the
first level that we share in this
pyramid and let me call intention. So
your intentions have to be other
centered, right? You can't make people
the objects of your curiosity. You've
got to have the intention to really
connect with them and really hear a
little bit more about who they are and
that intention of curiosity makes a
really big difference in the way that
your conversations go. I hope this was
absolutely brilliant for you and that
you take this tool and practice it in
your own world and it may come
conversations less awkward. We care
about these ideas enough so like yeah
sure the book's available on Amazon but
you can also go to the link below and
download a free PDF of the book that
unpacks intention that tool that I just
shared as well as I held up this giant
question. There is a deck of cards that
I've created called We Connect Cards and
they're filled with 60 of the best
questions to ask to skip past small talk
and really create conversations that
matter. And so if any of that interests
you
check the links in the description to
learn more. I'm Chad this was awesome. I
had a blast hanging out in cyberspace
with you. I hope that our paths cross at
some point in pixel land or real life.
Have an awesome day filled with zero
small talk. And if you want to go much
deeper these two videos will dive you
further into this path of creating
conversations that matter. Cheers.